Traduttore: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
È per me un onore essere qui oggi,
e mi sembra stranissimo
essere su questo tappeto rosso,
se penso che fino a dieci anni fa
la mia vita ruotava intorno alla vela.
Passavo tutto il mio
tempo libero in mare -
non solo le giornate calde,
meravigliose dell’estate siciliana,
ma anche quelle fredde, invernali.
E ricordo come fosse ieri
la sensazione di avere le mani e i piedi
completamente congelati,
alla fine degli allenamenti invernali.
E devo ammettere che ero
così presa dalla vela
che non mi ero nemmeno accorta
che fosse arrivato Internet.
Uno dei miei primi incontri con Internet
è stato quando ho preparato
la tesina delle scuole superiori.
Ricordo che non sapevo ancora bene
come cercare le immagini online
e, alla fine, sono finita a fotocopiare
delle immagini dai libri della biblioteca
e appiccicarle con la colla sulla tesina
perché non sapevo ancora
come cercare le immagini
e inserirle in un testo
scritto a computer.
In dieci anni,
la mia vita è stata stravolta
dalla rivoluzione digitale.
Internet è stato il mio ponte,
dalla Sicilia al resto del mondo.
Ma il momento che mi ha veramente aperto
gli occhi sulla rivoluzione digitale
è stato qualche anno più tardi,
quando ho scoperto la stampa 3D.
E l’ho scoperta proprio
guardando un TED Talk,
quello di Anthony Atala.
Questo professore parlava
della stampa 3D di organi umani
e della promessa di salvare la vita
di centinaia di migliaia di persone
con questa tecnologia.
Una cosa fantastica,
e per me assolutamente
fantascientifica a quei tempi.
Mi ha incuriosito tanto
che ho deciso di vedere
una stampante 3D con i miei occhi.
E sono stata fortunata a trovare
un corso di stampa 3D a Bruxelles,
la città dove vivevo a quei tempi.
La descrizione di questo
corso mi rassicurava,
perché diceva che chiunque,
perfino una persona come me
che aveva studiato economia,
poteva imparare a stampare
in 3D in poche ore.
E quindi mi sono buttata.
E ho fatto bene a buttarmi
perché quel corso, in poche ore,
mi ha permesso di creare
un portachiavi col mio nome
stampato in 3D.
Non era stampa di organi,
ma era stampa in plastica, semplicemente;
però quel portachiavi è bastato
per farmi vedere la tecnologia
con occhi diversi.
Come uno strumento di creazione,
piuttosto che come qualcosa
da utilizzare passivamente.
E quello è stato per me
l'inizio di un percorso
che mi ha portata,
qualche anno più tardi,
a fondare una start-up specializzata
in stampa 3D per dentisti,
e anche a fondare il progetto Teens4Kids
che vorrei condividere oggi con voi.
Sto lavorando su questo
progetto da tre anni,
con un team fantastico di volontari
che, come me, avevano voglia
di investire sul futuro della Sicilia,
e di riportare in Sicilia
quello che avevano scoperto
nel loro percorso in giro per il mondo.
Insieme stiamo creando un ponte
che porti gli studenti in Sicilia
a contatto diretto con le innovazioni
nel resto del mondo.
E vogliamo mostrare, e portare,
una visione della tecnologia
come uno strumento attivo di creazione.
L'idea di questo progetto è nata
vedendo in prima persona
quanto fosse profondo il divario
tra realtà innovative -
come quella di Silicon Valley -
e altre realtà - come la Sicilia -
dove la tecnologia
viene subita, più che creata.
Alla base di questo divario
c’è, innanzitutto,
il fatto che oggi ci sono
pochi creatori digitali.
Per esempio, nelle comunità online
si parla della regola dell’1%:
cioè che soltanto l’1%
degli utenti di una comunità
sono creatori di contenuti.
Mentre tutti gli altri sono contributori,
e soprattutto consumatori passivi
dei contenuti creati da qualcun altro.
Viviamo in un mondo in cui pochi
creano contenuti, e servizi,
consumati da milioni,
o miliardi, di persone.
E la cosa più preoccupante,
è che non solo ci sono
pochi creatori della tecnologia digitale,
ma anche questi pochi creatori
sono concentrati in alcuni stati
e nelle grandi città.
Questa concentrazione di creatori -
e il divario, in generale,
tra i creatori di tecnologia
e i consumatori passivi della tecnologia -
secondo me è uno dei problemi
più grandi del XXI secolo.
E rischia di creare
profonde diseguaglianze,
economiche, politiche e sociali.
Credo sia un problema
che dobbiamo risolvere adesso,
e iniziare a risolvere a partire da oggi.
E in questa transizione
verso il mondo digitale,
i nativi digitali
sono specialmente vulnerabili.
E non è quello che normalmente pensiamo -
che sono nati col digitale,
quindi sono naturalmente
più vicini al digitale.
Perché, di fatto, questi giovani
sono nati in un mondo
in cui Internet è dato per scontato,
e spesso non viene messo in discussione.
Se vediamo i nostri teenager nelle scuole,
oggi molti di loro sanno utilizzare
Internet in maniera passiva
e sanno utilizzare
i social media e Instagram.
Ma quanti di loro sanno
utilizzare Internet in maniera attiva
per creare contenuti,
o per sviluppare idee imprenditoriali,
o per risolvere problemi sociali?
Ma non sono qui per parlarvi
di quanto, secondo me, sia urgente
una riforma del sistema
educativo in Italia.
Penso che siamo tutti d'accordo sul fatto
che il nostro sistema educativo
ancora non si è adattato
alla rivoluzione digitale
e che non sta formando creatori
protagonisti nell'era digitale,
se non ovviamente
in alcuni casi eccezionali.
Sono qui per parlarvi di come credo
che tutti noi, nel nostro piccolo,
possiamo contribuire
a risolvere questo problema.
E possiamo farlo partendo dal basso,
dalla nostra realtà locale,
anziché aspettare che qualcuno, dall'alto,
riformi il sistema educativo.
Nel nostro caso siamo partiti da Marsala,
la città dove sono cresciuta,
nell’estrema punta
occidentale della Sicilia.
Immagino che alcuni di voi
conoscano Marsala per il nostro vino,
ma immagino anche che non molti sapranno
che Marsala è anche la città del vento,
con tantissimi appassionati
di vela, come me.
Penso che ci siano
tre ingredienti fondamentali
per diventare buoni velisti,
che sono gli stessi tre ingredienti
che utilizziamo nel progetto
"Teens for Kids".
Il primo ingrediente è la pratica:
fare vela si impara
veleggiando, non sui libri.
Si diventa buoni velisti
buttandosi in mare
con tutte le condizioni:
con le cadute, le risalite
in barca, le ricadute;
con i pianti quando ti senti
persa in mezzo al mare;
con le vittorie e con le sconfitte.
E passando ore e ore
a contatto con il mare.
Il secondo ingrediente è il team.
Quando ci si allena in un team,
si cresce insieme.
Quando facevo vela,
ricordo che vedevamo ogni allenamento
come una piccola gara:
si imparava dai più grandi
e si insegnava ai più piccoli.
Con il team giusto
si arriva insieme al traguardo.
Il terzo ingrediente è l'ambiente.
Marsala è una città
con condizioni ideali per fare vela:
tanto vento; un mare meraviglioso
che fa venire voglia
di non scendere mai dalla barca;
e temperature che permettono
di allenarsi tutto l'anno.
Questi tre ingredienti -
la pratica, il team e l'ambiente -
sono i tre ingredienti
del progetto Teens4Kids.
Partiamo dal primo: la pratica.
Se vostra figlia vi dicesse
che vuole diventare una velista,
le comprereste mai un libro?
Spero di no: la vela si impara in acqua.
E allo stesso modo,
la tecnologia si impara
toccandola con mano, usandola,
e non solo sui libri.
Se vogliamo che i nostri studenti
diventino creatori,
devono imparare a toccare
la tecnologia con mano
e saperla usare in maniera attiva.
Non è importante che apprendano
una tecnologia specifica,
perché comunque qualsiasi cosa
apprendano oggi
sarebbe obsoleta tra qualche anno.
È importante, invece,
che apprendano una visione
della tecnologia
come uno strumento di creazione.
E oggi possiamo trasmettere
questa visione della tecnologia
attraverso le macchine
di fabbricazione digitale
come la stampante 3D e il taglio laser.
Immagino che alcuni di voi
non hanno mai visto una stampante 3D.
E immagino che pensiate
che siano care e difficili da utilizzare.
In realtà, non è così.
La fabbricazione digitale,
negli ultimi anni,
è diventata sia finanziariamente
che anche tecnicamente molto accessibile.
E qualsiasi scuola, oggi,
potrebbe permettersi di acquistare
alcune di queste macchine
e di creare un piccolo
laboratorio creativo a scuola.
Per esempio,
oggi si possono comprare stampanti 3D
che costano meno di €100.
E sul fatto che siano
tecnicamente accessibili
può garantire un'economista
che ha scoperto Internet dieci anni fa.
Nel progetto Teens4Kids
siamo partiti da 4 moduli di base:
la programmazione - o coding -;
l'elettronica; la stampa 3D
e il taglio laser.
E i nostri studenti apprendono
con le mani in pasta, attraverso il fare.
E soprattutto, giocando.
In uno dei nostri workshop, per esempio,
gli studenti creano
un microscopio fai da te
con le macchine di taglio laser.
Per la parte di elettronica
di questo microscopio
smontano una webcam,
poi prendono la lente della webcam
e la assemblano sulla struttura
che hanno tagliato col taglio laser.
E poi possono divertirsi
a personalizzare il loro microscopio
come preferiscono.
Durante questo processo di creazione,
gli studenti non solo apprendono
il disegno 2D, il taglio laser,
come smontare una webcam -
anche questa una competenza
fondamentale, nell'era digitale -
ma soprattutto imparano
a vedere la tecnologia
come uno strumento
per scoprire il loro intorno.
Con questo workshop
ho visto bambini, e anche adulti,
correre curiosi per la strada
a raccogliere foglie, insetti
e qualsiasi cosa strana trovassero;
ho visto anche alcuni prendere cotton fioc
e cercare i batteri della bocca
da spalmare sul microscopio;
e utilizzare il microscopio, veramente,
come strumento per osservare
e per essere curiosi.
E in più, questo tipo di progetti
sono progetti e strumenti preziosi
per democratizzare la scienza.
Infatti, questi microscopi
costano intorno ai €10
e permettono di avere
immagini come questa,
della stessa qualità
di microscopi digitali
che costano almeno dieci volte di più.
Una volta apprese
alcune competenze di base,
gli studenti sono liberi
di scatenare la loro immaginazione,
creando qualsiasi cosa considerino utile
o semplicemente divertente,
anche piccoli Pokémon.
E la tecnologia per loro
diventa uno strumento
per creare qualcosa
di cui essere orgogliosi.
Non importa cosa creino,
importa che siano loro a crearlo.
Immaginate se progetti come questo
venissero svolti dagli studenti
in tutte le nostre scuole.
Immaginate come potrebbe trasformarsi
la nostra educazione
se, per esempio, durante l'ora di scienze
gli studenti non solo
studiassero i batteri sul libro
ma imparassero anche
a creare un microscopio
per osservare i batteri
che stanno studiando.
In questo modo, la tecnologia non diventa
una nuova materia tra i banchi di scuola,
ma diventa parte integrante
del curriculum scolastico,
come vero e proprio
metodo di apprendimento.
Possiamo portare questo tipo
di educazione digitale creativa
in tutte le nostre scuole,
con gli altri due ingredienti
del progetto Teens4Kids:
il team e l'ambiente.
Non possiamo aspettarci
che tutti i nostri insegnanti
si trasformino in esperti digitali
da un giorno all'altro;
però possiamo facilitare
questa transizione
creando un team
che faccia leva sui teenager.
Nel progetto Teens4Kids
stiamo formando gli studenti
delle scuole superiori
per essere formatori dei più piccoli.
Quest’approccio ha tanti vantaggi:
innanzitutto, questi studenti
sono nativi digitali -
sono cresciuti con la tecnologia,
e quindi possono insegnarla
in maniera più diretta ai piccoli.
Inoltre, fare leva sui teenager
ci permette di portare
l’educazione digitale a scuola,
a costi e tempi molto ridotti.
E quindi di aumentare esponenzialmente
il numero di studenti
che possiamo raggiungere.
Nel progetto Teens4Kids
quest'anno a Marsala
siamo un gruppo di 10 volontari
che stanno formando 100 studenti
delle scuole superiori
che durante quest'anno scolastico
formeranno 750 studenti
delle scuole elementari.
A seconda dei loro interessi,
gli studenti delle scuole superiori
hanno ruoli diversi nel nostro progetto:
c’è chi svolge le lezioni ai piccoli;
c'è chi ci aiuta a prepararle;
ci sono alcuni che stanno
traducendo materiale, workshop
dall'inglese all'italiano;
e poi c'è un gruppo che ci sta aiutando
a gestire il progetto
come fosse la loro start-up.
Per questi studenti delle scuole superiori
il nostro progetto è uno stage formativo
che svolgono durante le ore
di alternanza scuola-lavoro,
uno stage che li sta formando
e preparando al mondo del lavoro,
ma anche al mondo fuori dal lavoro,
in cui potranno godere
di una visione della tecnologia
come strumento di formazione,
di impegno sociale e di cambiamento.
Insegnare è anche
il modo migliore per imparare,
e questi studenti stanno diventando
piccoli specialisti digitali.
Alcuni di loro hanno deciso
di continuare a studiare
in aree scientifiche e tecnologiche,
e quindi di iscriversi
all'università in queste aree,
ispirati dalle nostre attività;
altri hanno già creato
startup innovative a Marsala.
E una di queste, creata da teenager,
ha già 16.000 utenti in tutto il mondo.
Insieme alla pratica,
attraverso la fabbricazione digitale,
e un team che fa leva sui teenager,
c'è un terzo cliente fondamentale
per formare giovani creatori:
l'ambiente.
E mentre nella vela l'ambiente è dato,
e non si può modificare -
si può solo essere fortunati
a nascere e crescere in un posto
baciato dal sole e dal vento -
in progetti come Teens4Kids
l'ambiente si può disegnare.
Nel nostro caso,
per creare un ambiente
di apprendimento creativo
e per formare i nostri ragazzi
ci siamo affidati alle risorse
disponibili gratuitamente online,
incluse quelle da università
molto prestigiose, come il MIT e Stanford.
Abbiamo selezionato workshop, progetti
e interi corsi che stiamo
replicando in Sicilia.
E grazie a queste risorse,
stiamo offrendo un'educazione
digitale creativa
a costi intorno ai 10 euro a studente.
Un'educazione creativa,
al costo di un biglietto per il cinema.
Questo è il potere che ha Internet,
di rendere un'educazione d'eccellenza
accessibile a tutti,
in maniera democratica ed equa.
Ma devo ammettere che non è stato semplice
trovare le risorse per questi workshop
perché spesso non sono in italiano,
sono sparse tra varie
piattaforme, in varie lingue.
E nel progetto Teens4Kids
vogliamo contribuire
a rimuovere questo ostacolo
e a permettere a tanti altri
di buttarsi in progetti
di educazione creativa a scuola.
Per questo abbiamo deciso di lanciare
una piattaforma online, in italiano,
dove condividere workshop,
progetti e corsi,
a cui noi ci siamo affidati
per il nostro progetto
e anche quelli che sogniamo
di replicare in futuro.
In modo che chiunque volesse promuovere
un'educazione digitale
nella sua realtà locale
possa avere un punto
di riferimento da cui partire.
Ma perché questa piattaforma -
questo portale Teens4Kids -
faccia veramente la differenza,
il nostro contributo da solo
non è sufficiente.
Lanceremo la piattaforma a gennaio,
e nel frattempo vogliamo invitare
tutti quelli che, come noi,
stanno lavorando
per formare giovani creatori
a contribuire alla creazione
di questa piattaforma.
Abbiamo lanciato ieri sera -
creato da alcuni studenti
che fanno parte del nostro progetto -
un portale online
dove invitiamo tutti quelli
che vogliono contribuire al progetto
a condividere con noi progetti,
workshop, casi pratici, lezioni apprese,
qualsiasi cosa volessero mettere
a disposizione di tutti
attraverso il portale Teens4Kids.
In questo modo il portale può diventare
un punto di riferimento da cui partire
ma anche un punto di incontro,
di scambio di lezioni apprese
e di collaborazione tra persone
che vogliono fare la differenza
e portare questo tipo
di educazione a scuola.
Creando una rete basata
su sperimentazione e condivisione
possiamo far sì che,
da tanti casi isolati,
possa partire una rivoluzione
educativa dal basso.
Insieme, possiamo formare
una generazione di creatori,
di protagonisti dell'era digitale,
piuttosto che dei semplici spettatori
di questa trasformazione.
Tutti possiamo contribuire
a questa missione:
un insegnante può iniziare
con un workshop,
prendendolo dal portale Teens4Kids,
e farlo nella sua classe;
una studentessa universitaria,
o una teenager,
possono bussare alle porte
di una scuola elementare
e proporsi per fare
uno di questi workshop;
e da lì si passa poi
a intere scuole e a interi comuni.
E condividendo questi workshop,
e le lezioni apprese sul nostro portale,
l'impatto di queste iniziative
può moltiplicarsi.
L'attivista Bertha Calloway scriveva
che non si può cambiare
la direzione del vento,
ma si possono aggiustare le vele.
Quando si inizia a fare vela,
normalmente ci si lascia
trascinare dal vento
e si segue la direzione del vento.
Dopo un po' si inizia
a controllare la barca,
a decidere la rotta
e anche andare controvento.
Il vento passa dall'essere un ostacolo,
a essere un mezzo
per raggiungere una destinazione.
Con la pratica, attraverso
la fabbricazione digitale,
con un team che fa leva sui teenager
e con il giusto ambiente formativo
possiamo far sì che questa generazione
di studenti italiani
veda la tecnologia nella stessa maniera
in cui il velista vede il vento:
come uno strumento per raggiungere
la loro destinazione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)